[Music]
number one customer news Oh submitted by
a rock star that's me that's what you
know we start Steve is that your [ __ ]
wallet on the table this pro explain
what the [ __ ] is going on with this is
actually my wallet in a better condition
than normally isn't that the baby while
I compared to Michaels everything so
many things I got 30 grand near what do
you need to see daddy say me what do you
mean poor [ __ ] yeah exactly what's in
your wallet I don't know yeah exactly
mine's all receipts for expenses is [ __ ]
but that was before the internet I know
me about any card no everything's all
mine I know man but my wife makes me
ball of receipts rollers oh my god your
wife is that way too
I don't know if we can be very quiet no
she is like a purse I know there's a
duffle bag as a purse but to me that's
not that crazy cuz when I got with Nikki
she didn't have a personal and I made
her get purse yeah because because we go
somewhere and she would put everything
in her [ __ ] pocket and then when she
gets up I'll come down all was on the
seat I'm like your IDs like on the chat
yeah
do you not understand where like falls
in the ground so I'd always have to like
I always a dad her watching and like
holding her but this whole time that's
for sure if she loses it and she's like
oh my god where to go and then we got
his family a whole [ __ ] pay until we
go back and then I heard all the DB with
her all [ __ ]
I just just backpacks now man it's the
male parts at this point that yeah
before it was just like you would have a
key like a card maybe your ID or some
[ __ ] and then that was it but now your
[ __ ] phone is the size of a tablet
you have also there's like have you seen
the venmo debit cards it's smaller than
a credit card it's like this big really
does it go on your keychain she gives
keep that's mom I mean it's like a
credit card over here this one's like
that I love the genuineness in that like
free Twitter you really believe that
it's cute I just deal
yeah cuz then because a lot of people
they're like oh that's my bit that I
like small things but you it's
completely genuine I'm sure if any of us
have a bit on this show I think you'll
love it you aren't literally bits you
are best you you are the bit yeah
because you're such a joke Jill cuz
you're such a are you calling a [ __ ]
for just shortening and call me a bit no
no no I wouldn't climb that's not his
thing that's my did yeah we got that
only happens the first time I know about
it though I love it though it's always a
genuine thing I love it it's funny all
right
you're rebelling it oh my god postmates
has revealed that post Malone is its
number one most dedicated customer in a
year in a year off Bob we spend a good
amount do good but definitely not
anywhere near post about in a month in a
month so I'm probably ordered I was
probably ordering every day now I'm not
come on I like what's 300 times - all
right maybe like a couple grand I'm on
oh my god a couple grand a month
I think so you got a good customer but
she was pregnant for sure my buddy would
do it sometimes four or five times a bit
oh my god whoa okay never mind I thought
I was on the like post below number it's
like [ __ ] like $20,000 oh yeah
$40,000 dollars a year a month I don't
want none of us for the past year oh I
could totally see that cuz every once in
a while when I want to indulge and
really have the meal of my dreams for
one meal I'll get the Hat pastrami
sandwich chili cheese fries orange bang
and then I get like four pieces of fried
chicken from Popeyes then I get a fat
burger a burger from there and then I
get some boba like two things at boba
and that came out so I think like 200
bucks or something damn that's like
doing the rock well he gets on his cheat
day was crazy though if I crave
something I can't do it like that I
can't postmates it because then you're
going it doesn't taste the same I have
to eat it in there cuz it tastes way
better the promise when you would love
want three different things wherever you
drive it's gonna be bad if you want to
eat it together oh I'm gonna eat
together I just go separately oh no some
crave I'm craving it together
he likes to mix it the fat kid move I
love it yeah he has no patience I want
some fried chicken now like all together
and then the chili cheese fries and then
be a little bit Asian about it with the
boma
like this Saturday I'm like I've been
craving like mad Japanese food so it's
just gonna be a game over dude when you
go to the mall and you're at a boba
place in the mall it's all these white
ladies and the other pants have you
noticed that no no it's hilarious love
the boba the boba has crossed over well
I think it's cuz it's new to them no
trendies oh my god what is this sushi
yeah number one customer so in the past
400 days he spent $40,000 is he cool
with them talking about this you know me
like this is personal what the foot guys
I was up to remember her post mates you
can even buy like laptops and they send
it to your door yeah yeah he once tried
ordering a hundred guitars because he
wanted to smash him on tour and then he
tweeted out like postman's help the max
I can order is 10 help mu monsters he
has purchased from two hundred and
eighty nine different merchants oh damn
yeah he has more ordered more than six
hundred and sixty times in 52 different
cities nationwide for a total of three
thousand items Wow
yeah that's fun though cuz I imagine you
feel like you're on tour and you don't
know the area and you just want stuff
like brought to you I mean that sort of
makes sense if you got the money to
spend on it yeah but just spend it on
the guy who goes and gets it for you
yeah that's post meets BAM it's marked
up like hell though but that's cheaper
than having a guy hang a guy you're
gonna pay a guy a private guy to like
you know run around [ __ ] sure he does
yeah pretty sure you have you guys and I
need extra help yeah that's my post
beads there yeah we spent forty on right
so if he gets a guy for thirty-two but
they get the haul this guy around where
you ever you go it's just an extra
person
I'm not paying for you room and board
yes post mates if I absolutely have to
like I have to I've never used it once
I'm speaking meaning why
because I'm more Asian than you guys I
get apparently you are you are you are
you're right cause I'll tell Mickey I'm
like we're not [ __ ] yelping [ __ ] here
or whatever we call e 20 club all right
yep my dad [ __ ] is like $7 and somebody
come here I'm like I will go pick it up
outdoor time is money dude yeah but I
don't give a [ __ ] I will pick it up if
you got the time [ __ ] pick up my [ __ ]
no cuz you look forever away if I live
closer to you then yeah absolutely go
get it to save money I just eat at home
I just have food at home and I eat that
alright stop rubbing it in our faces
right not cook yeah like I cook amazing
food at home dude I literally just quit
[ __ ] like that's that's really what it
is for you but it's amazing for us yeah
stupid okay walk me through your egg
making process first I get ahead not
like what I've been eating on though on
them tell me about the [ __ ] eggs how
do you make a name what do you know much
how do you want it you want to poach so
you want it really you want it polish
things if you gave me six hours like in
four days
how do you make your aim well if I want
it scrambled you get a knob of butter
you put it into a nonstick pot you
already lost me at the novel but how
much is it nice like however much you
want had a NGO just throw the hole let
me feed your child some nutritious so
I'm saying I did tasty Tuesday for Nicky
like last week and and it says like oh
you got a simmer to this thing I don't
like what the [ __ ] does that even mean I
know what summer means bro but I'm like
I don't know what this means and then
it's like oh well you need to make sure
that you some you zest the lemon what is
that it's just the peel right I think
reading it it's not easy to just like
jump into cooking yes sure cuz I think
something and then it said like beets
this right and I'm like [ __ ] what you
punch that [ __ ]
I used to beat it like a fork of [ __ ]
whisker what's what David says I want a
knob of butter and I'm like dude I will
beat the [ __ ] out of you what is enough
tell me what about yeah we get stuck on
some basic [ __ ] yeah sorry how much is
it not good that's why why'd you poach
me I say I need post me that's why I
care yeah I'll put it to you like that I
that's true I'm a little different
though because like for example like the
other day like Mariel wasn't having a
good day and so like use if I make her
food it makes her feel good so like she
wanted like plumcots a'right class is
gonna be like a chicken cutlet park
awesome person yeah that's $30 drinks a
ass pity doll mill just went to the
store I bought the pork loin I already
had the bread crumbs and it cost me
[ __ ] 8 bucks don't make it sound so
simple do that hate you go to [ __ ]
hell to buy ingredients he could've just
bought the thing class was the easiest
thing you could ever [ __ ] make you
know how do you even make breadcrumbs
bro okay are you gonna quit its moist
huh you can toast it throw it in the
oven you like sand the edges I want you
to do it tasty Tuesday read a book and
you do it yourself cuz I want to see you
great a piece of bread a lot of [ __ ]
believe me even get it to where he can
greet it though I need you go get a
grater okay this is a I think um great
soft that's why I'm such a big fan those
[ __ ] companies like blue apron or
what are the ones I mean I'm losing
something cuz it comes with everything
to step by step and I'm like oh I felt
like that's cool I like that no this
[ __ ] was telling me he's like okay mix
sugar in with water and wait for it to
granulate or some [ __ ] and I was like I
think it's granulated no cookies ever
said and it looks like it's like taking
the sugar is in the water and then it
started to burn and I could smell it we
making caramel milk so if you want to
make like toffee you would add like
butter to it the other one yeah so you
can make like caramel that way yeah yeah
so then I stirred it and then I think it
was but I didn't know I didn't know and
that's what scares me you see so you
can't you can't be like it's not easy
all you do this is because she wanted to
stay only but it's not like it is easy
though you know what they're doing
you're over here with your privilege I
mean ooh hey I'll give me a nighttime
look on your face I'll figure it out
I'll go on the noon I'll figure it all
look like a [ __ ] loser but I'll
figure it out though no you want
guarantee you I will hum this video is
gonna come to you wait for it on the
BART and Gio YouTube channel give me I
giving you [ __ ] me give me like a couple
months I'm thinking I should a couple
money if I know we see at night time
look you're talking about like do the
cat's-eye on all things you give me like
a couple of months and I'll figure out
how to do makeup that's cuz I literally
had to do it on Excel practice that you
know [ __ ] if you give me a couple of
months tonight that's why I'm saying
it's easy you practice it [ __ ] yeah but
it's not easy to start what you're
saying is try to do makeup tomorrow and
I'll figure it out is anything difficult
David all right have you got it all
figured out
yeah all figured out
[Music]